got a little video of Elon and what he's
doing at Twitter these days the same
standard should apply to me and supplies
to everyone on Twitter just as it is on
positive or negative
so what do you do same for everyone now
that's another thing that that a lot of
traditional journalists don't like is
they don't like being put on the same
platform as the average citizen they
don't like their voice being it's the
same they're pretty mad about that yes I
uh there are several news organizations
who don't like your push for
democratization and what they believe is
the devaluing of the badges because they
were differentiated so is that just a
moment does
just a moment in time
no that's deliberate I think it's very
important for
to to elevate citizen journalism I think
it's very important to hear the voice of
the people the actual voice of the
people not the filtered voice of the
people and let the people choose the
narrative and let the people determine
the truth
and not five editors in Chiefs of major
Publications
do you want to know what's really going
on or do you want their opinion you know
it's a handful of people I think
I think we want to know the voice of the
people the true voice of the people this
does get us to that starting point uh of
the elites versus the people and RAV
there's an awful lot of Elites and
formerly blue check journalists who are
very upset and not willing to pay eight
dollars to still have that blue check
and you know get some of the benefits
thereof
yeah well Dave you know we should we
should really hold our thoughts and
prayers for the the blue check mark
genocide all these people who can't
afford eight dollars a month I mean I
mean how many how many Spotify or
Netflix or crave or HBO whatever
subscriptions that these people have and
how much time are they spending on these
things I mean eight dollars a month is I
mean it's I think you said it's a price
of a coffee or whatever like the
Meltdown over these little things on
Twitter this is the point where I get
where like I'm looking at all these
people melting down and I'm like I need
to get off Twitter because this is a
fake reality this is like a
hallucination this is not real this is
like this is like the most trivial of
trivial problems and I need to go
outside and like they'll touch the dirt
or something and do something in their
real hands because people are whining
about eight dollars a month but other
than that like what Elon Musk just says
uh in this clip is absolutely right I
mean this explains the rise of substack
how leading Publications you know
throughout the pandemic especially and
in other issues have gotten things
completely wrong I mean the Atlantic the
New York Times on lockdowns mask
mandates vaccines
Etc they have gotten these issues so
wrong and they've failed to hold big
Pharma accountable for what they've done
you know Pfizer moderna and the CDC and
the FDA and misleading the public and so
that you know that explains why so many
people are now subscribing to sub Stacks
where you know independent journalists
like myself can freely write about
vaccines and write about mandates
without any fear of an editor uh you
know editorializing or changing things
Jay I assume that elon's words are music
to your ears because obviously you were
Shadow banned and then suspended and
then ultimately banned banned from
Twitter by the old regime reinstated by
Elon uh do you have confidence that that
this thing's going to work out properly
and that he can you know keep it in
defensive free speech and the rest of it
Elon Musk has done in Twitter is
actually quite Brave I mean he's
essentially telling the government to go
take a flying hike at uh flying leap
whereas like you know you look at
Facebook you still have this censorship
regime going on
foreign